la fortune des français selon un rapport
de l'insee l'écart s'est creusé en 25
ans invité de notre journal l'économiste
robert lattès une réussite médicale sans
précédent grâce aux ultrasons que
médecin suédois réussissent l'avortement
d'un jumeau le pont wilson ne pourra
être sauvée de nouvelle arche s'effondre
la ville de tours privés d'eau marée
noire les fermiers de la mer sans
ressources
le témoignage d'une goémoniers
madame mademoiselle monsieur bonsoir
l'avortement encore diront certains
d'entre vous et c'est vrai nous vous en
avons beaucoup parlé depuis quelques
mois et quelques années en france les
autres aujourd'hui c'est d'un avortement
très très spécial dont nous voudrions
vous parlez les médecins suédois ont
tenté il ya quelques mois une première
mondiale n'avons appris leur succès
aujourd'hui je vous raconte brièvement
l'histoire l'an passé dans une ville du
sud de la suède
une femme est enceinte les médecins font
des analyses tout va très bien mais ils
s'aperçoivent tout de même que cette
jeune femme attend deux enfants des
jumeaux deux enfants certes le rêve pour
certains cas seulement voilà aux
alentours de la 24e semaine de grossesse
ces mêmes médecins s'aperçoivent aussi
d'autres choses et là une chose beaucoup
plus grave
l'un des deux enfants est atteint d'une
maladie extrêmement grave
s'il vient au monde il ne sera pas
normal et les médecins prennent une
décision dramatique ils vont tenter de
prélever le foetus malades et laisser
remplace le foetus
le petit enfant qui lui est bien portant
alors aujourd'hui nous pouvons vous le
dire tout a très bien réussi
l'opération a réussi l'enfant qui
restait dans le ventre de sa mère
pendant neuf mois et les normalement au
bout de cette grossesse il est
actuellement en pleine forme
martin à la réunion il s'agit là d'une
expérience tout à fait extraordinaire
mais je crois qu'il faut le dire tout de
suite qui ne peut être pratiqué que dans
des circonstances très très très
particulière c'est un cas très rare mais
il est intéressant parce qu'il permet de
montrer un certain nombre de choses dont
deux prouesses techniques et qui vont de
pair avec les progrès de la médecine
une décision importante et puis une
preuve de sagesse vous en parlerai tout
à l'heure alors la première prouesse
c'est d'avoir pu diagnostiquer une série
de choses pendant la grossesse de cette
femme et ça commence par un recours aux
ultrasons qui permet de diagnostiquer
les jumeaux nous allons vous en montrer
un exemple maintenant j'ai une femme qui
est porteuse d'un enfant bien portant
vous verrez ça n'est pas cela qu'on
l'appelle l'échographie l'échographie
ici la membrane qui sépare les deux
qualités dans lesquelles se développer
les jumeaux donc ce sont des faux
jumeaux et voyez à l'endiguement
qui remuent chaque fois que l'un des
deux s'agite on a un petit mouvement de
la membrane et l'autre l'a toujours il
est toujours plus agitées ce vécu pareil
pour l'instant j'ai l'impression ça vous
fait de voir c'est extraordinaire ça de
les voir et de les ouvrir et de les voir
vraiment on n'a pas l'impression la
partie pour les voir et les entendre
il bouge c'est un décor très bon film
et le bourhis et puis ça sent les
mouvements brusques
oui c'est une bonne des images
étonnantes c'est vous respecte et qu'on
ne voit pas ça bien sûr je venais de sa
cour alors ce ne serait pas une prouesse
mais une série d'autres aux actes qui
ont consisté à voir si c'était des vrais
et des faux jumeaux ont même s'il était
dans une seule poche ou dans deux poches
car ça n'était possible que si c'était
des faux jumeaux ce qui était le cas
dans quelle situation ils étaient et la
nature de la maladie pour pouvoir être
assuré que cet enfant a été anormal et
ils ont pu diagnostiquer une maladie où
l'enfant était présumé idiot un
squelette déformés et sans doute aveugle
et mourant avant l'âge de 15 ans et
c'est alors qu'ils ont pris la décision
de l'avortement thérapeutique
la deuxième prouesse technique a
consisté à dire on fait un avortement
strictement thérapeutique
on prélève l'enfant anormal mais on va
essayer de garder les biens portants
pour ça il faut obtenir une césarienne
qui permet de n'intervenir que sur l'une
des deux poches sans toucher à l'autre
évitez les contractions utérines
inquiète très difficile et là encore je
crois qu'ils ont réussi et ceux ci et a
donc beaucoup les obstétriciens acquis
leur tire un coup de chapeau
et puis alors je vais terminer en vous
disant tu es une preuve de sagesse dans
tout ceci parce que cet événement s'est
passé il ya quatre mois il est médecin
suédois par jour ne m'ont pas parlé ils
ont attendu que l'enfant soit né à terme
est normal alors qu'il avait la preuve
de l'anomalie des autres pour le faire
savoir à la presse et au monde entier
merci martin je vous le disais cet
avortement thérapeutique bien sûr et
lieu à la 24e semaine et dans ce cas
précis il est incontestablement
nécessaire mais il ya aussi des enfants
qui naissent à 24 semaines le professeur
minkowski qui était notre invité samedi
midi nous le disait alors regardez ces
images elles sont dures certes je le
crois mais ce sont celles d'un enfant né
à six mois et qui pèse un tout petit peu
plus de 600 grammes
la taille de cette enfant oui la taille
de la main par rapport à la taille de
l'enfant
il est déjà formé entier nous l'avons vu
samedi il bougeait
jusqu'à hier matin la ville de monsieur
jean royer c'est à dire la ville de
tours avait trois ponts sans raison
apparente
elle en a plus que deux aujourd'hui le
pont wilson le plus vieux de la capitale
de la touraine s'est effondré morceau
par morceau i hier matin et hier
après-midi et puis même aujourd'hui il
n'y a pas eu de victime le seul
automobiliste qui était sur le pont à ce
moment au moment de l'effondrement a eu
un bon réflexe au lieu de freiner quand
il a vu que tout bougeait il a accéléré
et à peine était-il sortie du pont que
ce dernier s'effondre et dans la loire
qui est actuellement en crue aujourd'hui
on s'interroge alors que cent mille
personnes à tour sont privés d'eau
puisque les canalisations passait sur le
pont on s'interroge pour savoir ce qui a
bien pu causer la chute brutale du
tabligh l'après-midi de nouvelle arche
du pont wilson s'effondrait il faut dire
que la crue de la loire n'arrange rien
le vieux pont de pierre comme
l'appellent les tourangeaux et le plus
grand ouvrage permettant de franchir le
fleuve à tour il est long de 400 m et
supporte une chaussée à quatre voies la
nationale 10 cet effondrement
spectaculaire étonne et inquiète comment
cela at-il pu arriver
ceci est le résultat je crois des crues
de cet hiver qui se sont succédé
c'est un phénomène naturel et
le phénomène physique puisque les
dernières inspections que nous avions
fait sur cet ouvrage n'avait pas montré
de défectuosité dans le sommet de cette
fondation nous périodiquement tous les
cinq ans nous procédons à des
inspections de ce type des hommes
grenouilles interviennent avec des
moyennes télévision subaquatique
dégarnissent et ça met des fondations et
examine la situation de celles ci nous
n'avions pas à l'automne 1976 observé
sur cet ouvrage de désordre
en attendant la ville de tours est
condamné à vivre au ralenti cent dix
mille habitants sont privés d'eau en
effet une grande partie de la cité est
uniquement alimenté par une conduite
enfoncé dans le tablier du pont
depuis ce matin des camions citernes
ravitaillant les habitants néanmoins
certains hôteliers ont décidé de fermer
leur établissement et de nombreux
touristes ont quitté la ville côté
circulation la saturation est à craindre
car le vieux pont était l'un des plus
empruntées
si cet accident n'a pas fait de victime
un automobiliste peut dire qu'il l'a
échappé belle à 10 centimètres près il
plonge avec sa femme et son enfant dans
le fleuve
puis j'ai vu la faille dans le pont et
une voiture qui faisait rugir sans
moteur alors là c'est assez pathétique
parce que la voiture verte qui étaient
là bas était littéralement devant un mur
de goudron elle était dans le creux de
la faille et elle tentait désespérément
de s'en sortir
ban pour ce groupe e devant moi qui vous
étiez en train de rouler sur le pont
normalement et puis qu avez-vous senti
bagis on y invite quoi sur moi bien et
depuis lors je suis content et j'ai
accéléré pour remonter le sujet royer
maire de tours infirmer que les travaux
débuteraient rapidement les chantiers
fonctionneront jour et nuit dans
l'immédiat un pont métallique sera
édifiée à une vingtaine de mètres en
amont de l'ouvragé d'être si l'on en
croit le patronat français le cnpf les
choses vont nettement mieux depuis le 19
mars l'économie française repart les
experts du pas de relation catégorique
l'attitude prudente contesté jusqu'au
milieu du mois de mars à peu près a fait
place à un retour de la confiance qui se
traduisent par un déblocage des
commandes notamment dans le secteur des
biens de consommation
un point noir toutefois dans cette météo
optimiste la situation financière des
entreprises françaises n'est pas
brillante pour le cnpf les entreprises
françaises sortent d'une longue période
d'activité ralenties leur trésorerie est
extrêmement maigre et leur volonté
d'investissement risquent d'être bloqués
par l'insuffisance de leurs ressources
du côté des familles et nous restons
toujours dans le domaine économique cela
va probablement moins bien selon l'insee
qui publie aujourd'hui même une brochure
je vous montre rapidement selon l'insee
donc le patrimoine des familles les plus
riches de france s'est enrichi durant
les 25 dernières années beaucoup plus
vite que celui des familles les plus
pauvres de france
il ya 25 ans philippe sassier les cas
était de 15,7 l'écart aujourd'hui est de
plus de 28
oui dans cette étude du dernier numéro
d'économie statistiques de l'insee
on voit notamment que l'écart entre les
revenus notamment les salaires entre
1949 et 1975 a eu tendance à se réduire
en revanche l'écart entre les fortunes
les patrimoines à dire tout ce que
possèdent les français a eu tendance à
s'accroître alors nous allons demander à
les auteurs de cette étude dominique
strauss kahn de faire pour antennes de
hacker un calcul spéciale on lui a
demandé si vous aviez 100 francs 1949
qu'est ce qu'ils sont
venu selon que vous étiez riches au
départ ou selon qu'on était un peu plus
pauvres alors voilà ce que ça donne et
voir sur ce tableau c'est assez étonnant
voilà 100 francs en 1949 dans un
patrimoine qui n'était pas investi qui
était mal protégé qui reste et comme
l'on dit lick it à dire dans une caisse
des panneaux sur un compte en banque et
bien en 1975 un quart de siècle à 110
francs
en revanche 100 francs dans un
patrimoine élevé dès le départ qu'ils
s'étaient bien protégé qui était bien
diversifié keitel et nous aurons un
petit problème n'arrivons pas à avoir
votre carte pourront alors je ne sais
pas si nous allons pouvoir le transférer
le changer de place pour tout le monde
c'est peut-être sur sa caméra voilà puis
donc fêté ses mouvements sur cette
caméra alors murisier encadrait 949
pouces offrant pour un patrimoine qui
était mal investi un petit patrimoine
quelqu'un qui n'a pas utilisé son argent
pour acheter de la pierre pour acheter
de la terre pour acheter des valeurs
mobilières c'est à dire se placer en
bourse via ses 100 francs sont devenus
110 francs un quart de siècle plus tard
bon sens frank était bien placé en 1949
qu'on était bien investi dans
l'immobilier dans les forêts etc dans la
bourse est bien intégrée tout en 1964
740 sans oublier les cas besoin énorme
de 1962 et 1975 qu'est ce qu'il s'est
passé on reprend toujours sang-froid
dans le petit patrimoine et bien on
retrouve sans enfant et ceci sans tenir
compte de l'érosion monétaire donc en
fait avec la place on a beaucoup perdu
d'argent et le safran du gros
patrimoines ils sont devenus 300 francs
parce qu'ils étaient beaucoup mieux
protégé donc vous le voyez l'inflation a
tendance à augmenter les écarts et bien
évidemment entre le petit parking
patrimoine et le groupe patrimoine et
bien les écales aussi se sont énormément
accrue envers la terre est ce que vous
avez écrit récemment la fortune de
france alors est ce que l'on peut dire
réellement que plus on est riche plus on
devient riche c'est à dire que l'argent
va à l'argent
il est parfaitement exact car en un
certain niveau de fortune comme disaient
nos grands mères on peut beaucoup plus
facilement ne pas mettre tous les oeufs
dans le même panier on peut également de
temps en temps faire des arbitrages dans
les éléments d'un
monde fortune pour un autre et il est
absolument certain que cette manière là
on a la possibilité de mieux défendre
son patrimoine et on a je vois qu'ils
jouent insisté sur le caractère un peu
statique et irréel de cette comparaison
je voudrais donner un élément pour ne
pas rentrer dans des détails beaucoup
trop technique c'est que l'expérience
prouve que les petits patrimoines ont
souvent quelques ligue louis d'or or ils
se sont pas trop mal comporte en 25,1 et
d'autre part l'expérience prouve aussi
que quand on fait ce genre d enquête et
bien premièrement on ne cherche pas à
saisir lors et il faut le dire et
deuxièmement eux-mêmes spontanément les
gens dissimule dans les enquêtes qui
possède de l'offre puisque je crois
qu'il faut se méfier de certaines
appréciations qui manque parfois un peu
de nuance mais comment peut-on mieux se
protéger contre l'inflation parce qu'en
définitive si l'argent va à l'argent
parce qu'on sait mieux se protéger
contre l'inflation c'est certain si on
prend un exemple et tant d'années le
problème logement de l'immobilier étant
donné n'oublions pas que l'immobilier
avec était quelque chose de très mauvais
comme placement entre 1918 et 1939 il
certain que toutes les fois qu'on a pu
faire des opérations d'accession à la
propriété d'achat ou une infirmation
terrain depuis 1949 1950 contenu ce qui
a été notre société cela a été une des
meilleures façons de protéger son argent
bien meilleur que de la garder en argent
liquide ou en argent de caisse d'epargne
cette différence quand tu as quand même
à diminuer et maintenant elle tend à
diminuer cela étant il voudrait faire
une remarque que les gars je crois les
les auteurs de l'étude que vous évoquez
reconnaissent et il est très difficile
de comparer une société à 25 ans
d'intervalle
je voudrais prendre un point très
important tout le monde reconnaît
aujourd'hui les hauteurs de votre quête
d'ailleurs invaincu lié qu'un élément
très important du patrimoine c'est la
capitalisation des droits à la retraite
or la société française de ce point de
vue là entre 1949 et 1975 à fonder mon
changer le nom des gens qui avaient ce
genre de droit était très faible et leur
montant était très faible en 49
aujourd'hui il concerne la quasi
totalité des gens à petit revenu et pas
de petit patrimoine et à revenus moyens
ils patrimoine moyen pour dire les
chiffres en 75,7 capitation des droits à
la retraite représenter environ 30 % de
la fortune des français mais se
concentrer essentiellement sur les
petits patrimoines et les patrimoines
moyens hors cet élément capi légion des
droits à la retraite n'est pas intégré
dans l'étude que vous évoquez je crois
qu'il ya là une distorsion très
considérable qui est lié à une évolution
très profonde de l'assister française en
25 ans par la ts merci toujours dans ce
chapitre économie le gouvernement ouest
allemand a annoncé aujourd'hui qu'un
sommet économique des pays occidentaux
se tiendra les 16 et 17 juillet prochain
à bonn durant ce sommet le canada les
etats-unis la france l'italie le japon
l'allemagne la grande-bretagne
s'attaqueront d'ibn aux grands problèmes
économiques actuels sur la base d'un
soutien réciproque entre chacun de ces
pays le baron charles victor brac est
mort nous l'avons appris ce matin le
baron brac avait été enlevé par des
gangsters il y a trente cinq jours une
rançon avait été demandée une rançon de
50 millions de francs belges soit à peu
près 8 millions de francs français
mais d'après ce que l'on sait les
ravisseurs du baron bras que durant tout
le temps où ils ont négocié avec la
famille l'avait en réalité plus d'otages
l'industriel belge était mort dès les
premières heures de l'enlèvement mort
des suites des blessures qu'il avait
subies au moment du rapt
le roman noir du baron bras qui s'est
terminée dans ce sous bois le mystérieux
correspondants qui se fait appeler des
hommes danger a rompu son silence de
trois semaines pour annoncer dans son
mauvais anglais le corps se trouve là
il s'agit bien du baron princes de la
finance qui était partout au brésil en
australie au zaïre avec l'huile en
europe avec l'hôtellerie en vacances et
au camping avec trigano une personnalité
qui a fait croire aux ravisseurs que la
fortune était au bout du calvaire de
l'industriel seulement le baron n'a pas
résisté
il ya 48 heures encore la famille
gardait espoir en pin libéré il fallait
faire un appel au mystérieux des hommes
diaboliques
dix messages directs et un tour de passe
vous connaît s10 auront surtout au 10
août et peintes et de captivité of my
father you must know in realizes la
danseuse weeks and his wife is quite
great city bike days and life hier au
lendemain de l'appel des comme drame
révèle que le corps a été jeté dans une
décharge le baron est mort depuis plus
d'un mois
au début de son enlèvement d est un
assassin
le baron bright une fin tragique le
baron empain en france un succès pour la
police deux enlèvements qui sont le fait
de gangsters mais il y aussi les rapts
politiques l'allemagne a connu le cas de
monsieur hans martin schleyer l'italie
connaît en ce moment même la sphère aldo
moro dans ce dernier dossier rien neuf
aujourd'hui on sait que monsieur aldo
moro a adressé hier un nouveau message
au chef du gouvernement italien une
lettre très grave a reconnu ce matin le
préfet de police de rome un document
impressionnant écrit par un aldo moro
méconnaissable
ce terrorisme suscite bien sûr de
grandes craintes en europe les ministres
de l'intérieur d'italie d'allemagne de
l'ouest d'autriche et de suisse se sont
réunis durant le week-end pour discuter
de l'intensification des opérations de
lutte contre cette forme nouvelle de
délinquance politique
une réunion importante dont rien
officiellement de la file très bonne
michel meyer
nous allons entendre michel meyer tout
de suite en direct de bonnes
officiellement cette rencontre de zurich
doit permettre aux autrichiens aux
italiens aux suisses et aux allemands de
l'ouest de renforcer leur coopération
dans la lutte contre le terrorisme
cette coopération policière est déjà
assez bonne entre l'italie et
l'allemagne fédérale
une preuve depuis le début de l'
enlèvement moraux des policiers ouest
allemands sont en italie pour
précisément aider soutenir leurs
collègues italiens les allemands sont
par contre beaucoup moins heureux de
leur coopération avec de très neutre
suisses et autrichiens dans cette lutte
commune contre le terrorisme la
frontière germano suisse est considérée
ici comme une sorte de passoire un
gruyère suisse dit on avec une déception
un peu malicieuse
par ailleurs on a la certitude depuis la
sphère buback l'assassinât du procureur
buback et la sphère flat hier que ses
coups de main on était préparé depuis la
suisse les policiers allemands ont aussi
la certitude que la mitraillette ayant
servi à l'assassinât du procureur buback
a été acheté en territoire suisse et que
les comptes bancaires des terroristes et
allemands se trouvent eux aussi en
suisse en allemagne justement à
stuttgart
le procès de m klaus croissant a repris
aujourd'hui m klose croissant est
accusée vous le savez d'avoir aidé
certains membres de la bande à baader à
quatre reprises des audiences de son
procès avait été suspendu pour des
problèmes de procédure
cette fois-ci il semble bien que le
tribunal ira au fond des choses
la sphère de l'utilisation des bombes à
fragmentation par l'armée israélienne
lors de l'offensive au sud liban israël
affirme aujourd'hui que ces bons n'ont
été utilisés que contre des unités
d'artillerie ou des postes avancés de
fedayins qui ne cessait de bombarder les
villages israéliens
une mise au point qui ne satisfait pas
entièrement les américains pour ceux ci
c'est bon ben vous envoyer l'un des
éléments ne devait être utilisé que si
israël était attaquée et non pas lors
d'opérations de représailles
le président algérien monsieur royrie
boumédiène a félicité aujourd'hui
monsieur raymond barre à l'occasion de
sa reconduction au poste de premier
ministre en france le président algérien
ouvre d'ailleurs largement la porte du
dialogue entre paris et alger
l'algérie écrite il apportera toute sa
contribution pour imprimer à la
coopération franco-algérienne
l'impulsion qu'elle mérite
enfin c'est une société française la
thomson csf qui fournira tout le
matériel de télévision nécessaire pour
les jeux olympiques de 1980 des jeux qui
vous le savez se tiendront dans la
capitale soviétique à moscou cette
société devrait fournir ainsi une
centaine de caméras couleurs une
quarantaine de télé cinéma couleurs et à
les charger également d'établir les
faisceaux hertziens qui assureront la
retransmission des jeux de moscou dans
le monde entier l'espagne est peut être
le pays qui ces deux dernières années a
le plus changé en europe des changements
surface cela tous les touristes qui se
rendent de l'autre côté des pyrénées
peuvent le constater jour après jour
mais aussi des changements en profondeur
et ce sont ceux-là qui sont probablement
les plus importants car l'évolution
aujourd'hui à madrid a atteint les
moeurs certes endroit l'adultère est
toujours puni de prison en espagne mais
en fait les choses ont beaucoup changé
de l'autre côté des pyrénées on parle
maintenant librement divorce et
contraception
certes on n'étudie pas encore dans les
universités mais on en parle déjà entre
femmes
l'espagne n'est pas l'italie la bataille
du divorce n'y aura pas lieu
ce détective le sait il y a quelques
années un client sur quatre lui confiait
un problème matrimoniale à résoudre
aujourd'hui la proportion est descendue
à 1 sur 10 c'est l'état d'esprit qui a
changé pas la loi
on ne divorce toujours pas en espagne on
peut tout au plus avec un bon dossier
obtenir une séparation légale et
l'église qui avait été un verrou
supplémentaire est aujourd'hui plus
progressiste que l'état se marier en
espagne ne sera plus grâce à la
prochaine loi de divorce synonyme d'
impasse juridique et la femme séparée de
son mari pourra vivre sans être à
l'index
il a fallu quand j'habitais dans des
quartiers mettant du côté de gardiens ou
alors bonjour
exactement il fallait que je dissimule
que je dise que mon mari était en voyage
ou bien qu'ils étaient très occupés ou
qu'il était médecin et rare il faut
comme toute la journée
maintenant surtout dans le quartier dans
lequel j'habite qui est habitée par des
jeunes surtout vous bien des
professionnels ou l'état la mentalité
est un peu plus libéré
les choses ne se passent pas tellement
comme ça je peux dire tranquillement que
je je loue un appartement mois comme fan
j'ai un enfant je suis séparé et c'est
une femme divorcée en espagne
aujourd'hui ça reste une femme sans
honneur oui pour certaines personnes
pour d'autres on tombe dans l'excès
opposés parce que pour certaines
personnes
je progresse qu'on appelle sont les
modernes
c'est une au contraire c'est une tarte
de présentation si tu arrives dans un
endroit à tu dis moi je suis séparé
jeunes enfants c'est ça fait bien
l'espagne qui sans bruit dépénalise
l'adultère s'apprête aussi à se mettre
au diapason dans un autre domaine aussi
important celui de la contraception la
législation de l'ancien régime toujours
en vigueur l'ignorent ou plutôt la
réprime l'information du couple les
espagnols ne savent pas ce que c'est
sauf à fréquenter des centres comme
celui ci animé par des mouvements
féministes dans un appartement
ces semi clandestin tolérer 3000 femmes
ont fréquenté celui ci l'année dernière
à madrid c'est trop de monde et presque
personne à la fois il ya beaucoup de
gens qui sont venus il y en a même trop
puisque
il n'y a pas la possibilité avec
nombreuses femmes d'établir un contact
humain de voir réellement les problèmes
de chacune que chacune que ces femmes
discutent entre elles et ça devient
comme un centre de la sécurité sociale
on voi x client par heure et l'on vient
chercher un cachet d'aspirine s'en va de
l'aspirine plutôt la pilule a nié le
problème de la contraception le
conservatisme n'a pas pu barrer la
frontière aux contraceptifs la pilule se
vend sur ordonnance et sous des
prétextes thérapeutique qui n'ont rien à
voir avec les faits que les femmes en
attendent sous la pression de leurs
patientes
les médecins au cd pour les d'autres
méthodes comme le stérilet eh bien il ya
un an les médecins qui le pose ici et
même qui font une bonne affaire opposant
mais il y en a d'autres qui les posent
qui ne font pas on affaire n'est
simplement pas ce qu'est on comprend que
c'est une méthode qu'on doit aux que
j'ai qu'on peut utiliser mais la plupart
nés ou bien ils ne veulent pas savoir
et là il ya aussi mais là j'ai une
question
ils ne savent pas ce qu'ils n'ont pas
appris les visas ne sont pas prêts
piquez la contraception et pour le
moment je crois que on est en train
changé qu'ils sont en train chargé mais
il leur faudrait renseignements bon
grâce est immense et un niveau inédit
cassien des médecins divorce
contraception de nouvelles conquêtes sur
le machisme au pays du machisme
mais c'est surtout un pas vers une
démocratie plus quotidienne la liberté
pour chacun de choisir à chaque moment
de l'existence
si dieu site de cette évolution bruno
alves notre envoyé spécial à madrid a pu
pénétrer la semaine passée dans ce
centre de contraception pour assurer ce
reportage il ya seulement six mois
aucune caméra ne pouvait filmer ces
règles michael wilson est mort hier à
los angeles il était âgé de 63 ans
michael wilson c'était l'un des plus
célèbres scénaristes d'hollywood on lui
doit entre autres les scénarios où les
scénarii pardon des films le pont de la
rivière kwaï la planète des singes que
récemment
enfin pour les vacanciers de pâques qui
avaient l'intention de partir peut être
demain
demain en italie sachez que les pilotes
d'alitalia sont en grève depuis hier et
que jeudi prochain ses pilotes
d'alitalia seront rejoints dans leur
mouvement revendicatif par tous les
syndicats italiens de transport aérien
sur les côtes de bretagne dans un avion
pour y aller
le travail de fourmi continuer les
vacanciers qui se rendront sur les
plages dans les jours qui viennent
pourront se rendre compte du triste état
des côtes
certes certaines plages sont déjà
nettoyé mais si le mazout a causé
beaucoup de dégâts
le nettoyage par lui-même n'a guère
arrangé la situation et ce cas est très
précis notamment pour les goémoniers
légal money ce sont ces hommes et ces
femmes qui vivent de la vente des algues
pour certains c'est une activité de
soutien
mais pour d'autres c'est leur pain
quotidien ainsi pour marie marie de
castelmore en bretagne une bretonne
comme beaucoup d'autres et qui tape pas
eu la vie facile vraiment pour moi c'est
terminé puisque voyez vous la chanson
est urgent de gagner ma vie encore ses
530 pression de la nation de la petite
peste comme au mali était pêcheur et
bien il faut que je travaille encore
pour le compliment pour pour me
débrouiller autrement mais je ne vivrai
alors de quoi quelques verdict il des
gens moi y en a plus y en a plus il a pu
rien du tout maintenant je suis
déterminé alors pour les algues mais non
c'est fini aussi et mon goût et vous qui
sait qu'il aime le payez vous mais alors
je ne demandais je ne demande qui c'est
qui va me payer
j'avais pour le 500 comment que les 5000
francs actuels cas où 6000 francs sur la
grèce mais c'est fini terminé mais non
ils sont là tous thomas ajouté jeffrey
cadre peut-être peut-être deux je vous
fait cadeau de mon goût et volaille
qu'amener à paris allez après mise à
l'épreuve
monsieur le maire a offert aussi un plan
à kuopio à peine 20 ans plus une chose
et je lui ai dit que j'avais eu des
drames a l'air de ma vie plus que la
marée noire actuellement gelés
je n'ai jamais témoigne à la commune de
pout vrai et d'ailleurs je ne suis pas
encore dans l'intention d'y aller
instruments pas j'ai encore mes bras qui
sont assez costaud pour ces filières
tous ces choses là mais non je vais
fumer pathak puisqu'il me reste encore
mais moi j'ai un petit coin tel qui n'a
pas été empoisonné par le mazout et
c'est encore la légère et 5 pouces qui
vous donne tous les jours à la gsr trois
ou quatre pattes à dix puis à neuf mois
et j'aime rigoler alors oui les maris
les journaux anglais danny sofinim à mes
poules pour nous toujours la love et mes
patates sont dans le coin il aurait pas
nous analysé à le coup dans la commune
pour aller manger chez piolot thématique
mari de castelmary avait découvert ont
régalé il ya quelques jours avec trois
mois d'avancé sur la saison les premiers
melon ont fait leur apparition ce matin
sur le marché de cavaillon malgré cette
bonne surprise la météo de demain ne
sera guère meilleure que celle
d'aujourd'hui sur la provence des alpes
le jura les vosges beaucoup de nuages
aussi des plis apparition d'éclaircies
l'après-midi sur le reste du pays tant
variable avec alternance d'éclaircies et
de giboulées les températures seront
encore assez basses pour la saison et
les vents de nord-ouest soufflera assez
fort voilà à 23 heures c'est gérard
holtz qui vous présentera le dernier
journal je vous souhaite de passer une
excellente soirée non pas sur europe 1
numéro 2 mais sur antenne 2 bonsoir à
tous à demain
à